Let's briefly talk about magnetic tape, which is usually
used for backup purposes or so-called secondary storage, which
means that the magnetic tape is not the first
device on which you look for your data. You first
try to find your data on the hard drive. And only if it's not there, you go to
secondary storage. Either because the hard drive was lost
and you need to restore and back-up or because this
data was not used for a long, long time, so it was stored on tapes and put away
somewhere. Tapes can have large capacity and are usually
replaceable. Meaning you just bring a reel of tape and
you attach to the tape machine. But their access
is fundamentally sequential. We need to seek along the tape
until we find the point we are interested in.
So tapes are very good for things like back-up restoring
back-ups and so on when you're writing things sequentially
for a long time or reading them sequentially for
a long time. But tapes are not very good,
for example, as a virtual memory or something like that.
Tapes are slowly dying out, mainly because they have
a low production volume because not many people actually use
tape. So the cost of tapes is not dropping
as rapidly as the cost of disks, which have much
more mass production, so their cost gets cheaper over
time. And at this point, it's cheaper to buy
an entire hard drive together with all the motors
and the head assembly and a built-in electronics for
it, than to buy some tape and the machine
that will read it. So people for example, use
USB drives which is pretty much an entire hard
disk just packaged with a USB interface, as a method
of backup storage and so on.